all right fall of
Satan what does the Bible have to say
about the fall of Satan if you read
contextually Ezekiel 28 and Isaiah 14
contextually it's not about Satan let me
repeat this
again let me sum up because there's some
other stuff I want to talk about
contextually Isaiah 14:12 to 15 and
Ezekiel 28 11:19 is not about Satan it's
about the king of Babylon and the king
of Ty and the destruction that will
befall them that God will bring upon
them for their arrogance into thinking
they are Gods on Earth the sons of gods
goddesses who think they can oppose the
true God and get away with it I already
went in depth on those two chapters
showing
why with that said with that
said Can what is said about the king of
Babylon and the king of Ty apply to
Satan in other words though it's
referring to historical Kings who in
their arrogance think they're Gods on
Earth sons of the the the gods and
goddesses of their
pantheons though it's referring to Kings
and God bringing Swift destruction upon
them showing that they're nothing but
maggots can it by
extension
apply to Satan or an evil spirit ruler
that works in and through these evil
Kings yes it can why because in Daniel
10:13 20 to 21 we are plainly told
Daniel 1013 20 to 21 we are plainly told
that human rulers have Spirit
beings working in and through
them inspiring them influencing them
manipulating them to bring about the
evil and the
Havoc upon the Earth that's Daniel 10:13
20-21 it's right there when the angel
tells Daniel right I wanted to come and
relay to you the answer to your prayer
because immediately you were heard when
you prayed but it took me 21 days to
reach you why because the ruler of the
do domain of Persia detain me that's
Daniel 1013 What ruler would be able to
resist a spirit being a mighty spirit
being who to human eyes is invisible
unless God opens our eyes to see him
it's not the human ruler it is the
spirit ruler working in and through the
human
ruler so the Bible does teach Behind
These human rulers are Spirit
rulers Spirit beings that manipulate
them Inspire them influence them to
bring about great evil havoc and
destruction upon the Earth and that's
what Paul says our battle is against in
Ephesians 6:12 in Ephesians
6:12 Ephesians
612 watch
here thank for last for posting for we
wrestle not against flesh and blood but
against
principalities against Powers against
the rulers of the darkness of this world
against spiritual wickedness in high
places see Paul is saying you're so
focused on the human being in front of
you you're so focused on caesar no our
battle is not against Caesar per
se our battle against is against the
rulers the principalities the
authorities and the Heavenly Realms of
the kingdom of darkness that are working
in and through human
instrumentalities to bring about evil
and destruction our battle against them
if we disarm them we set the human
rulers
free singing
in so you want to make sure did you
catch
that if you caught that what's the point
when you go back and listen to those
sessions and understand them by the
grace of God here's the point let me sum
up Isaiah 14 Ezekiel 28 those chapters
are not explicitly about Satan so if
you're trying to use those chapters to
describe the origin of Satan and his
fall you can only do so implicitly
because it's not explicitly talking
about Satan someone can disagree with
that ex interpretation say well
contextually it's about the king of
Babylon who's an arrogance thinks he can
rival the true God and contextually it's
about the king of Ty who in his
arrogance he thinks he's a God on Earth
it's not about saying so I disagree with
that
interpretation with all that said is
there anything
explicit when it comes to the fall of
Satan is there anything explicit do we
have something explicit about Satan
falling well it all depends on 1 Timothy
3:6 and how you read it 1 Timothy 3:6 no
Revelation 12 is not about the fall of
Satan Satan is already fallen he's
already an enemy he's already evil in
Revelation
12 it's 1 Timothy 3:6 in giving the
qualification of an
elder and giving the qualifications of
an elder who is qualified to be an elder
it says an elder should not be someone
who's a recent convert a novice less
being lifted up with pride because of
the position and Status he fall into the
condemnation of the devil now what does
it
mean that he's condemned like Satan was
condemned or that his pride will be used
by the devil to get him condemned by
God you get it if you go with the King
James rendering condemnation of the
devil can mean that through Pride Satan
will tempt him so that God will destroy
him for his pride so it's a satanic
Temptation causing them to be filled
with pride resulting in his destruction
or is it saying that like the devil was
condemned because of Pride and conceit
he too will be condemned because of
Pride and conceit now let's look at how
other versions render this passage can
you give me the
NIV
NIV NIV Eric am am I doing so far Eric M
am I right he must not be a recent
convert or he may become conceited and
fall under the judge same judgment as
the devil so the ni is telling you that
the Greek means like the devil who was
condemned he'll be condemned for the
same sin the devil was condemned and
judged for conceit he too will be
condemned and judged if he's
conceited yeah I know you saw you see
how the NIV rendered
it let's see how the new King James
version renders
it the new King James version renders
it not an noice less being puffed up
with pride he fall into the same
condemnation as the devil so now these
two versions say that the
Greek most
accurately
means that like the devil was condemned
aavas a recent convert who becomes a
bishop and is given that kind of status
and authority and Prestige will be
conceited and be condemned as a result
so according to these
renderings the devil was condemned
because of conceit the devil was
condemned because of Pride the devil
destroyed himself because he become
became arrogant conceited and proudful
so Christians be careful guard your
heart don't end up becoming conceited
proudful or arrogant lest you too